[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
what should be checked el attr
[Musique]
ma meilleure je crois que c'est
poelvoorde ils ont dit qu'ils allaient
planter les cerisiers du japon est ce
que tu crois qu'ils l'ont fait oui l'ont
fait mais se sont arrêtés là c'est ça
qui est dommage 1 combien de fois le
poids du corps pour les nains rémy 30
fois les eaux sont peureux rémy
mois prise d'entre vous laisse compléter
les jeunes seront la priorité de mon
quinquennat la suivante mon premier
ministre sera vous le serez le lendemain
du second tour
le président de mon ennemi sur à
l'islamisme la suivante moi ma première
visite officielle sera à bruxelles pour
leur expliquer que ça va pas être pareil
qu'avant et la dernière - présidente la
france est ma passion
aux signaux
initiaux et
[Musique]
m
sans et bourzat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]